pailloux tonnes les cloches ville des
noms familiers des tourangeaux mais qui
sait aujourd'hui que ces noms de rues ou
d'hôpital c'est en grande partie à des
femmes qu'on les doit certaines d'entre
elles se sont pourtant montrés
exemplaires
malheureusement
la femme s'efface souvent derrière le
mari
ou derrière le fils une derrière l'amant
derrière loeb et cela fait longtemps que
sylvie pouliquen travail à rues de deir
une visibilité à toutes ces femmes
oubliées j'ai d'abord travaillé sur la
résistance en général en parlant de la
résistance je me suis aperçu que
beaucoup de femmes
s'étaient illustrés moi même dans ma
famille j'ai ma mère ma grand mère qui
étaient des résistantes mon père était
résistant et déporté mais les femmes
n'ont pas été les dernières loin de là
après femme de londres son premier
ouvrage consacré aux résistante elle a
publié deux autres livres pour présenter
ces dames de touraine injustement
méconnu plusieurs associations se
mobilisent pour sortir toutes ces femmes
de l'oubli comme osez le féminisme qui
entendait mettre les tourangeaux à
contribution on a fait ça par les
réseaux sociaux un grand appel à
participation avec un formulaire très
simple à remplir pour nous dire un nom
de femme c'est date de vie et de mort et
puis son oeuvre en disant on va recevoir
une dizaine de noms de femmes et on
pourra faire une exposition quelque
chose et on a reçu plus de cent vingt
participations donc on a été très
surprise et étonnée par à la fois
l'engouement et puis en fait le fait qu'
il suffit de poser la question pour
avoir des noms de femmes donc c'est pas
qu'elles n'ont pas existé c'est bien
qu'elles ne sont pas dans nos livres un
succès inespéré donc il en résulte une
exposition itinérante pour mettre en
lumière ces illustres inconnus d'autres
initiatives sont nés comme ces ateliers
wikipédia pour soutenir la création de
fiches sur toutes ces femmes oubliées on
s'inscrit dans un projet qui est le
projet des 100 pages sans s à eynesse
qui vise à rééquilibrer un petit peu
cette absence des femmes dans wikipédia
le but c'est aussi que les personnes qui
sont là s'empare de cette cette
technique et continue chez elle un
travail de longue haleine pour cette
réhabilitation
actuellement dans l'encyclopédie
participative
seuls 20% des pages sont consacrées aux
femmes